this hallway is mechanical engineering
and down here is applied biotics
my name is parker peter i used to be
just like everyone else just a normal
high school kid
until one day
little did i know that that spider had a
radioactive venom
which got into the water supply
[Music]
then something incredible happened
everyone got super powers
well everyone but me
[Music]
marco what are you doing now uh
nothing you know just uh slinging wet
oh good
i'm just going out for some errands have
a good day sweetie thanks for november
no one can know that i'm not spider-man
not even aunt november if anyone were to
find out they'd never look at me the
same
and today's a very important day
i'm gonna propose to my girlfriend jane
mary
but first i have to tell her the truth
about me
[Music]
look someone's on the ground
hey what's up hey look it's not
spiderman
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
damn it
i need pictures of not spider-man but
sir that spider-man doesn't like having
so many photos taken of him he's worried
the paper makes him look bad look bad
are you kidding me i've given him more
publicity than anyone else in new york
city and there's no such thing as bad
publicity
i need pictures of that not spider-man
on my desk by noon tomorrow or you're
fired by new tomorrow i need to meet
jane mary for dinner in a few hours
[Music]
did you say something
it's not easy being not spider-man but
i've learned that with a great lack of
power comes great responsibility
[Music]
jane mary i'm so sorry i'm late
so
how was your day oh i was so hectic my
boss is being such a pain in the
spinneret you have no idea he still
hasn't given me the reports i need to
finish my research
i'm sorry am i boring you no no no i
just have a lot on my mind
i'll get that
are your spidey senses off is that a
ring
yeah
i guess the spider's out of the bag
i am not spider-man parker jane mary
will you marry me oh
my gosh parker yes
yes
i'm so excited to be mrs not spiderman
[Music]
[Applause]
you